[Music]
an American it was like a coronation
Donald Trump had just won a straw poll
of delegates by a landslide he is the
one the conservative base wants to lead
the Republican Party into the
presidential election of 2024 but even
though he says he's made up his mind
Trump is still not announcing his
decision however throughout the speech
Trump kept pledging that the country
would soon return to what he called
greatness I won twice and did much
better the second time than I did the
first getting millions and millions of
more votes than in 2016 and likewise
getting
more votes than any sitting president in
the history of our country by far
and now we may have to do it again we
may have to do it again
the speech was pretty much the same as
the one he's been giving around the
country in recent months bemoaning the
Biden presidency for undoing what he
says he achieved during his four years
in the white house this week however
he's injected a few sentences about
Nancy Pelosi's visit to Taiwan she
played right into their hands because
now they have an excuse to do whatever
they're doing and I will tell you it
would have never ever happened in a
million years under Trump I can tell you
that he tried to steal the last election
a few days ago former Vice President
Dick Cheney released a campaign ad for
his daughter Liz warning Republicans
against supporting Donald Trump Cheney
is seen as speaking for the Republican
Party old God who may support the former
president's domestic policies but who
feel Trump's attempts at subverting the
last presidential election were the last
straw in our nation's 246 year history
there has never been an individual who
is a greater threat to our Republic than
Donald Trump it was clear that Cheney
had had no impact among delegates not
least because his daughter is one of two
Republicans on the January 6th
Commission in Congress the thing is
the problem
Dick Cheney was a war guy you know he
loved the war that's you know where this
country may you know you know made money
and I just wish that all of these
politicians would just they had their
time you know they had their time to
make a difference on this country just
shut up and let Trump do what he needs
to do as far as those here are concerned
the last presidential election was
stolen and in fact Trump's popularity
has increased in the CPAC straw poll by
10 points since the commission began its
hearings his status as a victim of an
establishment conspiracy has been
confirmed for those here as far as CPAC
is concerned the Republican party is the
Trump party now in addition if Trump
does run in 2024 there's the expectation
that the Republican establishment will
rally behind him anyway just as it did
the last time
Al Jazeera Dallas